[Music]
uh thank you everybody yes my name is
ganesh taylor and we're here today to
talk about memes
so
memes are everywhere but the term was
coined only a few decades ago by richard
dawkins to describe ideas and cultural
behavior that can be passed on from one
individual to another
he argued that memes are a stage in
evolution
and just as humans are carriers for
genes we're also carriers for memes
we don't so much choose our means as
they choose us
its critics however argue that meme
theory upends all human agency and
thought
so is meme theory an exciting new
framework that moves evolution forward
to account for concepts and culture
or is the very idea of a meme a
misguided and reductionist account of
what it is to be human
and is meme theory itself a meme and
it's success a function of evolution and
independent of it of its truth
so to our wonderful speakers
uh massimo
pelucci is a philosopher
philosophy professor excuse me and a
philosopher at the city college of new
york and former co-host of the
rationally speaking podcast his research
interests
include the philosophy of science and
the philosophy of biology
joanna bryson is the professor of ethics
and technology at hertiga school in
berlin and is a founding member for the
center
for digital governance
currently she advises ngos government
and transnational agencies on all
matters ai ethics and technology
since july 2020 professor bryson has
been one of the nine experts nominated
by germany to the global partnership of
artificial intelligence
hillary lawson is a post-modern
philosopher and a renowned critic of
philosophical realism he is best known
for his work on reflexivity and his
theory for closure which puts forward a
non-realist metaphysics arguing that to
close the openness of the world with our
thought and language and so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to throw out a
question and each one of our great
speakers is going to have three minutes
to address the question
so the question to start us all off
massimo if you'd like to step up to the
plate as it were is is meme theory an
exciting new framework to understand our
culture and how we think
no
amazing that's it thank you everybody
all right fine let me let me elaborate a
little bit about it
uh so mean theory first of all it's not
even a theory that's that's part of the
problem uh it is an analogy as you said
it came out originally out of the
selfish gene you know richard dawkins uh
an analogy with the selfish gene uh
dawkins was already criticized by
biologists for using the selfish gene as
an analogy let alone for them using an
analogy on an analogy
even dawkins actually a few years later
it is about
his interest in memes he said he
admitted that was just a way to explain
make a point about genes really
uh he didn't really mean that as a
serious theory uh some people did take
it up as a serious theory for for some
time as a promising
new way of thinking about what about
cultural evolution that that is really
what what it is about memes are supposed
to be
units of cultural evolution in analogy
to genes which are supposed to be units
of uh you know
biological evolution
but the fact is that after you know a
couple of books in a journal of memetics
that was uh in print for a few years
actually electronic for a few years the
whole thing just turned on into nothing
nobody's publishing things about memes
anymore
the journal genetics folded many years
ago because they didn't have anything
else to say
so as far as philosophy of bio of
science is concerned mimetics
is what is called the degenerate
research program
the generate in this case doesn't mean
that it's morally objectionable it just
means that it's not leading anywhere
one of the most uh influential
philosophers of science of the last
century
himmer lakatosh
thought out of ways of basically
assessing whether a scientific theory is
useful or not whether it is in fact
something that should be pursued or not
and one of his central ideas was that a
research program has to be generative
that is it has to keep producing ideas
experiments
results if it doesn't do that if it
stops doing that then the idea itself
may even be you know valuable
they may be it may be right even but if
it's not leading anywhere for a
sustained period of time then we should
probably think about other ways of doing
it in the case of culture evolution
there are other ways of doing it uh
people have been working on cultural
revolution for for quite some time there
are different approaches uh that have
been proposed alternate alternative to
mimetics one of which is referred to as
the dual theory of cultural revolution
which actually uh uh tries to merge our
insights from evolutionary biology uh
into the study of cultural revolution by
talking about gene environment gene
culture co-evolution
that one is actually being far more
productive there is a lot of people that
are working on it a lot of people that
are publishing on it so
the short answer is no that was a little
longer answer interesting okay joanna
what do you think is it exciting oh yes
but i wouldn't say it's new and and so
i and i wouldn't entirely disagree with
what massimo just said so let me uh
throw in a little bit more history uh
so the point of thinking about the
selfish gene
was that um
people couldn't explain things like
altruism they couldn't explain why bees
didn't all have baby bees that some of
them just would defend the nest
they couldn't explain things like
cooperation and so the idea is that
there's something that replicates
right and that's what we call the gene
there's something that is perfectly
replicating i don't know if you have
children but you might have noticed
they're not identical to you right so
you're not the replicator you're the
vehicle of lots of replicators and so
you have obligations um and and there's
like you know various things have been
sort of carried out about this that
you're that you'll do certain things for
your cousins and whatever depending on
your genetic relatedness to them you're
more likely to sacrifice so for example
with the bees
every single uh insect like that use
they're called these social insects that
that really uh sacrifice their own
ability to breed
they all uh pass through a point where
their parents were perfectly
faithful to each other which these are
insects so like parts broke off they
were perfectly perfectly faithful and
that meant they were just as related to
their siblings as they were to their
offspring so it was a viable way for
evolution to create this very very uh
cooperative thing so
memes now the thing about genes is you
might think oh we know them their dna no
it's not like you replicate your entire
dna dna stream that would be replicating
you
you you chop chop it up and there isn't
really a strong understanding of what a
gene is the parts of the things that get
replicated can even be overlapping with
each other okay so to the extent that a
gene is a thing i think a meme is also a
thing it's also useful to talk about
things
like it seems that with people unlike
most other species
we're willing to also sacrifice for
those who have the same ideas we have
that we don't necessarily share the same
genes with and so it may be a point
where it's useful to talk about
sharing uh memetic information like we
shared genetic information so for me as
a scientist i have found this a useful
metaphor and in fact i was at the
conference for bruce edmonds i hadn't
thought about this three years where he
announced that he was shutting down
a very silly journal that spent a lot of
time looking for the meme like i was
just talking about looking for the dna
that was mostly papers about looking for
the meme in
uh in an email
and and and yeah in spam emails that was
like most of the papers and and so he
announced that the entire thing was over
and he and and at that very meeting
myself and several other people gave
these great papers about actual cultural
evolution and talking about information
transmission models you know we had
agent-based models mostly that was the
kind of meeting it was um but i just
felt so frustrated that this this
journal had captured what it what
mimetics was supposed to mean done a bad
job with it and then somewhat heroically
was at least you know stabbed by the
editor and said okay i've given up on
this dumb idea
but the words should not have been
thrown out with that with that bathwater
interesting okay hillary
well
we
uh we usually think of our ideas and
concepts don't we as things that we have
you know you have an idea somebody else
has an idea
and uh that's the way we think about it
we have the ideas
and dawkins is
meme
thought or i take the point he never
elaborates this is a full theory but i
think it's in the blind watchmaker
actually
um
uh
he he inverts that on its head
and he says
uh we are the carriers for our ideas we
don't have the ideas the ideas as it
were just
have us in a sense
and
and to think of the the success of
concept as being somehow independent
whilst they they
they are competing
uh through us as vehicles but the it's
the concepts that are competing not not
us that are competing so this idea of
dawkins is an extension as has been said
by the other panelists of his
same sort of thought that he did with
gene theory so instead of saying that we
compete as species one species with
another he turns it on its head and said
it's the genes that are competing
and we are just the vehicles for those
genes
now
i'm not a geneticist uh
and i'm probably therefore not in a very
good position to judge just how
effective this is as a tool and uh
joanna i'm sure is in a much better
position to make that judgment but
uh
it's a it's an exciting shift in
thinking about what might be going on in
relation to
genes or memes and ourselves by turning
it the other way around and it has uh
explanatory power in doing that however
i think one of the
reasons that i think that dawkins may
have given up on promoting his own
account of memes
is because
it changes our relationship to truth
because instead of thinking that truth
is the outcome of what we think about
what do we get it right
truth seems to be an outcome of the
evolutionary competition between the
memes
and so dawkins doesn't have any obvious
way of trying to show that mean theory
is itself true if it's not adopted by
the species then it is no longer true
and i think the same is true of
evolutionary theory as a whole i would
argue that evolutionary theory as a
whole is caught in this story that it's
a story about evolution about how we are
where we get
where we get to but that story involves
the notion that um
we might get somewhere which is not a
true description of the world
and and there's the rub now
i would if dawkins was here he would
probably not be very comfortable with
the idea of giving up on objective truth
because he wants to attack uh religious
folk who believe in god and he just
thinks that's wrong
however i would encourage him if he was
on the panel to say you can keep your
meme theory and your gene theory
but you just have to give up on the idea
that they are discovering something
ultimate about the world and instead see
them as a powerful explanatory tool for
understanding how things might work and
for us being able to intervene and
improve
our lives and our way of understanding
species so i think that dawkins can have
it both ways he can have the mean theory
but he's got to give up the idea that he
might have discovered the truth in the
process of presenting it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas